today I want to talk about the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences this
is a website which has just full a
database full of sequences in fact the
the at the encyclopedia has been going
for nearly 50 years I mean it started in
book form and it's now grown into a big
website so it started off by a guy
called Neil Sloan and he for his
research he needed to just needed to
tell some sequences apart and he wrote
them down and he just started to collect
his sequences together they were on to
punch cards this is going back quite a
while now and when the internet came
along that was a nice opportunity to put
it online and there are now two hundred
thousand and more examples of integer
sequences so there might be things like
the prime numbers the square numbers
just sequences with special properties
the classic example like 1729 is a
important number in mathematics it's
part of mathematics folklore 1729 was
the number that ram anujan talked about
when Hardy asked him you know this is a
boring number can you think of anything
interesting about this number and he
said 1729 is the smallest number that
can be written as the sum of two cubes
in two different ways equal to 1 cubed
plus 12 cubed and it's equal to 9 cubed
plus 10 cubed so that's an interesting
that's interesting now in fact there are
other interesting things about 1720 now
that's not the only interesting thing
about it and so it actually turns up in
other sequences I'm just going to pull
out this is the paper that I'm going to
refer to in here it gives 1729 as an
example let's have a look
1729 is also the third Carmichael number
that means 1729 divides X to the power
1299 minus X
for all X or whatever value X is it will
divide that perfectly it's the third
Carmichael number it's also the sixth
pseudo prime number in base 2 which
means 1729 divides 2 to the power 1729
minus 1 minus 1 there you go so that's
called a pseudo prime it's the
thirteenth number that is one more than
a cube and here the last example they've
got here I quite like this one 1729 is
the total number of ways to express 33
as the sum of six integers again all
these different properties first one
thousand seven and twenty-nine the point
is the more properties it has the more
sequences it appears in and I guess the
more interesting the number is so the
more often it appears in the
encyclopedia of integers the more
interesting the numbers would be so what
the guys who wrote this paper have done
is they counted how often each number
appeared in the encyclopedia of integers
and they looked at what pattern that
made now try and think of what pattern
you think that might make but this is
what they got and you can see it's quite
clearly a curve it decreases it's a
curve they found a little formula just
to describe that curve this curve I'll
write it on the paper
is 253 million divided by N to the power
one point three three so that's the
equation of that curve so these numbers
are appearing far more often in the
encyclopedia of integers these turn up
really often and then the ones that are
lower down here appear less often but
here's the interesting thing you can
quite clearly see in this curve a gap
appearing there is a quite clear space
here
and yet the numbers are actually forming
two bands so there's a top band which is
filled with
the popular numbers they're turning up
the most often then this is huge gap and
then underneath there's a bottom band
there which are your less popular
numbers they're the ordinary numbers
that aren't turning up so often and
that's quite surprising they could
generate this sort of curve if they had
a machine generating sequences and
integers this is exactly the sort of
curve you would expect so that wasn't a
surprise the surprising thing was they
have this gap separating popular numbers
from the less popular numbers now the
ones in the top band are actually
numbers like the primes all the primes
are there in fact almost all the primes
are in the top band about 95% of square
numbers are in the top band in the
popular band there are numbers like
numbers that are just perhaps one or
plus one or minus one of a power of two
so that'd be 2 to the power n plus 1 or
2 to the power n minus 1 or there might
be number such that have lots of factors
numbers that factorize into lots of
little factors these tend to appear in
the top band other numbers that appear
in the top band are ones that have
special properties in base 10 so numbers
like 1111 are in the top band a 2002 222
2333 all appear in the popular band of
numbers so what they think is happening
here is obviously this is cultural that
the popular numbers are the ones that
the mathematicians like these are the
primes or numbers that are related to
primes and they are they are elevated
above the ordinary numbers and so they
have a special place all by themselves
and they're elevated by such an amount
that you can see a quite clear space
between them
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this video and if you go to
audible.com slash numberphile you can
actually download a free audiobook now
there are loads of mathematics base
books we could recommend but today I
thought I'd recommend something a bit
different
The Fault in Our Stars by John Green
which is an excellent book I think it's
probably targeted a slightly younger
audience than me
but it's a book I really loved and
John's also a really great member of the
YouTube community and makes awesome
videos the books also just been made
into a film so you might want to get
ahead of the game before the film comes
out so again thanks to audible for their
support of our films and if you want to
check them out and maybe download that
free book audible.com slash numberphile
so in 2012 the smallest number that
didn't appear was a thirteen thousand
seven hundred and ninety-four tune in
Peter in the encyclopedia a talk now I
went and checked if that was still true
and I'm afraid that it is no longer
still true I think it's about four
sequences that that Bower appears in